un llamado a la apaciguamiento y al
diálogo el ministro israelí de defensa
rompió filas el sábado pidió al gobierno
que suspenda su plan de reforma del
poder judicial y que cesen las protestas
por el bien de la seguridad de Israel
por el bien de nuestros hijos e hijas el
proceso legislativo debe detenerse por
el bien de nuestra seguridad y de
nuestra unidad es nuestro deber Volver
al diálogo y recordar que todos somos
hermanos
advirtió que las reformas han agitado
los ánimos en el seno del ejército del
país en medio del enfrentamiento un
número crecientes de reservistas han
declarado que no prestarán servicio la
petición del ministro se produce en un
momento en el que los legisladores
tienen previsto votar la próxima semana
una parte clave de la legislación que
cambiara la forma de nombrar a los
jueces las reformas han desatado una
tormenta en el país el sábado los
manifestantes volvieron a reunirse para
expresar su descontento
[Música]
es el problema ahora es más grande que
él es más grande que todo no vamos a
volver a lo de antes
pero el gobierno de netanyahu afirma que
la reforma corregirá un desequilibrio en
el que los tribunales tenían demasiado
poder la iniciativa también llega cuando
netan Yahoo se enfrenta un juicio por
cargos de corrupción lo que hace que los
críticos cuestionen la razón detrás de
esta controversial reforma
[Música]